so now hello rejects I'm Greg
Alba and I'm John never say your last
name we're gonna review a film called
jaw here you're doing I've got it Johnny
I'm forgetting it you guys have the same
name same name Jonathan we're gonna
review John wick to chapter 2 after cue
today in this film I guess you know what
I'm just going to be that thing that I
love doing I'm going to read the IMDB
plot do it so the most efficient way to
get the point across video damn log line
B I can write my own version of the plot
after returning to the criminal
underworld to repay a debt John wick
discovers that a large bounty has been
put on his life Manuel is essentially
the plot of the next John wick film
alright so here's what we'll start off
by saying everything you've heard from
like Rotten Tomatoes example
yeah the action is like doubled down
yeah there's a lot of action in this a
bone crunching metal warping shell
casings like an action extravagant II
you that it is awesome this [ __ ] it is
some sweet sweet it's real sweet
kick-ass action the intensity of the
action sequences is still there for the
most part it's still there
everything really looks like it hurts
and they do double down on just the
sheer craziness of how fast everyone is
punching in the choreography and that
there's a lot of gun action to like they
definitely throw down on stunts
destroying car like there's a lot of
top-notch Jack and Keanu Reeves he kicks
ass again in this role so and I like how
boys you're watching this I was like I
wish you kind of got even at least
considered a little bit for an
oscar-worthy
role the reason why is because when you
look at these action sequences I'm like
hey you like months to prepare this is
like a dance you know Ryan Gosling sings
and dances in law online and everyone's
going what to do but then when the
Caprio climbs the side of a horse naked
and self-possessed and
Keanu Reeves was that it like tectus
yeah take down targets Linda Marshall
doesn't have much dialogue and he's best
performance he's ever given I think this
is the best character he's ever done
matrix was still my favorite Keanu
Reeves movie but this is my favorite
Keanu Reeves character and this film
does introduce some pretty cool
characters you got comma in here as CAF
champions passion passion common now
when I stop calling them true I was kind
of worried the fitting comment and sure
that for Terminator Salvation know he
remembers what the [ __ ] he does in that
movie and I saw man Suicide Squad
trailer now he dies like a lizard
Burstein and here they actually utilize
common yeah he got the girl you got to
be a guy in the hitman where he's a guy
he's at you know the rival like he's not
exactly a rival of John wick but he's in
for the most part rather equal hitman
hang on we're professional rapport yeah
um kind weird a like hello can hate you
but I really respect you it's like I've
seen an anchorman when Vince Vaughn
kisses Ron Burgundy say works yeah
that's pretty much their relationship
and they have a great hand to hand
combat fight scene yeah they're all
these things together are pretty
memorable and that's a nice brings but
yeah they have a great scene where they
just talk at a bar I feel like their
best the best scenes in this movie are
with John wick in common I would get on
board with you for at least a few of
those no that's what I was most
interested like every little tiger I
want to give away like everything that
goes on in there but like you said
there's a scene at a bar where they're
just talking that wasn't that was
interesting
even when Mike he kind of appears at the
subway station for a little bit I don't
know what exactly constitutes this there
is something of that storyline that does
still feel a little personal because it
allows them to sit down and have a
personal chat and allows them in that
scene when they're fighting together to
really get personal with like this is a
display of my skills versus your skinny
has a personal vendetta towards John
wick that's what makes it for a more
personal reason yes cuz here you got
kind of like multiple storylines going
on here can't give them all away but
this a lot of the posters that they have
of this we're like everyone has a [ __ ]
ton of guns pointing at John wick
perfect poster yeah
one's out to get John wick in this movie
it's like the first movie some dudes
fluxed up and brings him back in the
game and he takes care of that situation
i way most people understand in this
movie is it's basically everybody else
waking up we're going John wicks back
yeah one guy pulls him in and then from
there just everybody's gun is pointed at
John wick my ass like everyone's got
beef with John wick and Ruby Rose who
you see in the trailer she's pretty cool
she plays his character named eros eros
eros yeah she's uh she's a deaf girl and
she lived to death of Sasson and she's
awesome in it I thought she was really
[ __ ] cool and Laurence Fishburne he'd
barely in the film all you got no he's
in it was barely in the film
I mean Lawrence Fishburne show I told
you this in the Carly Laurence Fishburne
shows up to do the thing he shows up for
lately what yeah like I were running
into x3 I'm gonna bring some crucial
[ __ ] to your plot dude a cool character
and then I'm gonna leave again and it
was cool it was really cool because that
he's trailing in it just to go like we
won't if you Morpheus to me yeah yeah
and if you do get that feeling like when
they're just talking with each other or
just sitting down and talking it's like
I like seeing them talk to each other
again and I like seeing that they have
different dynamics it's not like mentor
and the one is you know there's very
different dynamics and why they're
speaking to each other one even the way
like Laurence Fishburne's character is
cool because his role in the movie also
helps expand the world which is part one
of John wick is seeing all the different
ways in which the crime organization
spans the globe and his little
operations really cool and he's also a
very colorful character and so it
brought a splash of something you know
engaging and you get in a villain who
you know just as annoying as the villain
in the first one annoying in the right
way kinda guy but yeah yeah
Santino Dantonio and he's that guy did a
pretty good job too like a pretty good
job you a punk but PISA is an intense
punk
ian mcshane is in it an Amex chain he
gets the due date it makes chains one of
the few returning characters yeah who
actually that you expand upon a little
bit more haven't served even more of a
purpose this time around yeah which I
was glad I did
so what I would say is this is a great
great action movie it's cool yeah now
that I got that out of the way I do have
some issues with developments missha's
to overall would say yes absolutely go
watch this movie at the blasts there's
something
is incredible action sequences Keanu
Reeves is great there's a lot of great
things in here so we want to save our
issues of the film for the later part
you guys don't think we hate this movie
because we don't because I feel like we
start off but I'm gonna might be
eventually later score yeah you guys
hate the thing everyone else yeah we're
like no we don't hate and we just had
some concerns but concerns me yeah yeah
yeah so there's a lot of cool [ __ ] in
this movie too love me I love John Woo
and the thing is like we want there for
them because the issues of stem from
having issues is because it is a sequel
to John wick it is a sequel to John
anyway and you guys remember John wicks
on illuminating it one thing that I get
to lead into it it doesn't feel anywhere
near as personal as the first one and
it's hard it's hard it's not something
as personal as the first one but this
really doesn't yeah I really feel like
it was until about 30 to 40 minutes in
where I was truly hooked and started
feeling for like the safety and the
concern for John wick and all that stuff
yeah feeling like more hooked into it
but even that has a preceded and before
that like initial point the first 20
minutes a lot of it is this like uber is
a great job with you sure of yeah not
wicked it was of this guy show for
little appearance right here yeah even
have like this really cool action
sequence from the very beginning but to
think about that for a second the first
movie doesn't have an action sequence
for a while into the phone yeah they
really build up like the reason for the
action before the action yeah starts and
this one they hit you with it in meeting
this one felt like John wick to rock and
roll yeah yeah you can I we were deeper
Joe is gonna take four words every 10
minutes is gonna kill half the division
Europe this film felt more like an
action film which is great is the first
one first one feels like an action film
to but everyone knows what made it so
special was it felt like more than that
it felt like a film the first one feels
like I actually film and this one feels
like an action movie yeah because it's
just really entertaining I don't feel
like I left this film as loud or as
impressed because a the personal player
is not there and one thing I really
noticed was the way the film was just
shot in general like this style the
lighting the tone it felt like a
action film yeah didn't have like that
cool serious with an underlying humor
touch like you put a vest in the car you
were saying like the first one had this
this other world that was still down to
earth I felt like the first one had like
the secret world that you could see
living in secrecy in our reality yeah
this one felt like there is a hidin
world they I don't see possible in the
real world you know yeah I'm looking for
a term to refer to that as because it's
something that like you know some
Tarantino films have it and and certain
of these kinds of action films have
where they do have a heightened style
and in a definite yeah visual look and
yet somehow they convince you that this
is believable without you having go what
the room and then this one there's a lot
more stuff like oh it's the movie so
they're taking advantage and it's like
what's the plot I think the plot itself
moving forward out of the first John
wick makes sense
yeah the calls that they make yeah I can
see those and I and I think it's a good
enough story for John wick to go in but
it does seem like this is an
inconvenience to his life you know
exactly yeah because it's just it's just
like John wicks killing like significant
amount more people
Parmalee just cuz he got [ __ ]
overlooking much like what have I do a
gift to him over and now he has to do
survive this is where the first one when
he was killing everyone you could feel
you're like [ __ ] you and Johnny but in
this one it's like well this is me it's
still up yeah it's gonna say like and
I'm kind of like what is he good yes
live I got I started getting to that
point in the movie where I'm like we
have to live for exactly yeah I don't
get I'm going to be what your motivation
is to stay alive ready to have yeah and
I Koreans in a certain other things that
happen later in the film that we won't
get into I'm wondering how this will
play for me on the second time around
because like maybe if I go and get it
and I'm just here to have fun I might
feel differently because it is yeah you
know we only saw this a couple hours ago
soon you know feelings might change
there is something to me that did feel
like it was missing a little bit like it
was missing a 10% or something to hook
me because I never found that it had
like a rhythm I thought some of the
editing was a little more choppy like it
had everything that I liked it also felt
a little lighter like the first ones
called
dark like an emotional dark tale of this
hitman this yes has humor in it
is emotional dark tail of this hitman on
revenge this one had more of like like a
a key let's you've seen rock-and-roll
cuz it's going I could refer to here
yeah there's like there's a part of the
middle where it becomes like a techno
music yeah and it's just like there
there are things were like every scene
in the first movie felt like it was
necessary I got why we were peering in
on this moment as opposed to any other
why it was this character and whatnot
and and this movie at least on first go
just wasn't as tight as that yeah it's
more logistical it's a more political
situation it's just who wants to kill me
where do I have to go okay let me get on
guns first any what it's missing really
is okay when I feel it when I say style
and tone I really when I if you watch
this boy I really even just watching the
trailer I was kind of worried about it
the lighting of it and I feel like the
issue comes down to with the lighting
with it not being as cool or astral
visually striking that's what I mean
like I didn't feel it's almost like the
action sequences are looking awesome
the catacomb spicing that you see in the
trailer is one of the best gun action
sequences I've ever seen there's some
brilliant choreographed action but in
terms of style of the way it's captured
I can't really define that for you in
this film John wake chapter 2 at least
as we were watching and had everything I
like about John wick it had the the cool
stunts and action it had gunfights
insists I said a badass Keanu Reeves
that interesting characters we got to
see the crime underworld and we got to
expand on it in this one and the thing
is I think something does come out of it
when you look at the cinematography
because I'll totally the first movie I
remember feeling like really no shot is
wasted here and in this movie I felt
like well this is just one way to cavity
right but they could have captured like
they're framing isn't as crazy and isn't
as like composed this time around
there's a lot more just like oh we're
going to get some coverage of this I
think it's because do they have the
issue of he's in New York but he's in
Rome for a lot of it that he's back in
New York and I felt like been lighting
and the feel of the darkness of New York
play such a significant part to the
first one the cinematography of the
first film accentuates everything that's
happening on it and the cinematography
of the second one just kind of shows you
yeah doesn't really help accentuate
anything it's just kind of there cuz I
feel that in John wick one when there's
no action sequences I thought it was
captivating yes I thought I was I
thought it was awesome here I'm like I
only thought it was really awesome when
there was action going on like even when
they're doing like Roman Continental and
they have like a couple of you I can
just show you the Roman side of what the
Continental is it's not exactly 100% all
that different when they do have that
scene they share in the trailer where
he's like shopping for guns that was a
cool thing the subtleties are what make
this movie the most interesting because
we know they can do cool action yes I
guess I wish there were more subtleties
like that yeah and some more finet like
I feel like this movie could have used
some finesse because I feel like
everything really works together as a
whole in the first movie this one like a
lot of stuff works but some stuff
doesn't the music - there was Manos or
the music where I feel like they kind of
ducked out the music every time there
was a fight team and they punched up the
music every time you're in the toxins if
they want it to feel a little more
rhythmic yeah actually was it felt like
John wake full throttle yeah yeah
exactly which which I guess in its own
way is cool and but bringing it back the
good stuff I like the way it ended sure
it ends in a way where it like okay we
shaft get a sequel now it does end
oh come on you know you got to get a
sequel with that ending yeah I'm just a
little more demanding it that way so we
can get a sequel yeah but I like the way
how it ends on a totally different notes
and how the first one end I'm not going
to get any like that doesn't give [ __ ]
away
but it ends in a way where I'm like
that's kind of a bold move for an it
yeah you know go big yeah you're going
down are you going on the dark rabbit
hole you're gonna spend it what but I
could actually major kudos for doing
that and in the finale though wasn't
definite like my big issue with this was
it wasn't like it's captivated by the
plot or the emotional stakes but the
finale definitely had a plot moment
where I was like I think everyone in the
theater when I went oh yeah
like is the first real qualms in your
life
oh no I get the whole reason for this
movie yeah yeah yeah yeah why yeah I get
it but why I definitely wouldn't think
don't watch it like no please yeah that
was a go watch it like the action scenes
make it totally rewarding because also
at least as of right now and just you
know from some of the other responds I
feel like you know this reactions may be
a little bit in the minority so I am
again curious to go see it again it may
be just there's a rhythm I noticed or
maybe somebody can explain it to me in a
way where I'll see something different
about it I basically feel as a
standalone film it's really damn good
when you compare it to the first strong
lick it just feels like there's a good
amount of things truly missing at its
soul yeah the first John wick is like
terrific and this is really like this
movie had that thing for me where I kept
on expecting it like the next scene it's
gonna get awesome yeah and it's still
like really cool most of the time but
only a couple times did you ever cross
over - [ __ ] it's that John yeah I mean
so I go that's rice we had a rating
system I would say this film is really
good really good yeah they really go
with good you know I really hope go
really good I'm feeling good right now
and I want to be feeling like a really
good or I don't know it's pretty good
because I felt like because this film
was really about it's action and I
thought the action was phenomenal and I
was like really hooked by when the
action scenes were going on it wasn't
like watching a Transformers movie I
don't like it it is crazy yet I'm bored
and you know like I didn't feel that
when I was watching this so I was like
this is some cool [ __ ] there all right
guys you can subscribe to the real
rejects John is reason to Jerry on
Twitter and Instagram the social media
manager of bloom house and the real
rejects and shout out to common high
comment I'm glad they're actually
writing a real role for you now
I mean it's Black History Month yes I
got it I got chef and women in horror
month to get out rind is a horrible
thing I think black people are rocking
at this month